all right we talked about the greatest
DJ of all time discussion I always you
know say that I in my opinion you are
the goat
um who are your favorite DJs let's go a
couple categories you're very vocal
about that too what's the like when you
say that like I just feel like there's a
point in time what's the reception that
you get when you say that even from
other DJs I'm curious I think I think a
lot of deep I think because like you
like tweet that like yo drum's the
greatest I mean what are we talking
about just I mean who's the other guy to
get a Grammy besides Jazzy Jeff right
Tyler has a Grammy does he yeah what's
on uh the Nipsey record that's right yep
so me Khalid Jeff
that might be it when it comes to DJs
the nipsy record was
wow yep shout out to Khaled yeah yeah
salute but who's your favorite Club DJ I
have two favorite I have two okay Mr
Rogers shout out to H-Town and DJ booth
shout out to boof boof just did um
but is he he's Nikki's DJ right yes he's
Nick he's DJ and Fab and he was Fabs
yeah Super Bowl he hopped on when Fab
jumped on yeah buffer Mr Rogers are like
my like
I hate playing after them [__] like
they're cold bro I hate it like Mr Rock
like Mr Rogers
he does a better DJ Drama set than I do
wow like one one year we were on tour
we were in Houston and I had an after
party
and this [__] just like was in the club
giving me my flowers
and like the drop the the DJ Drama yo me
and Lake was sit we were like how am I
supposed to go on now blown away like yo
this [__] just [__]
and then Booth is another one like you
know I will I've I've seen booth on tour
we just did the legends of the streets
tour and that had to be a crazy Tour by
the way it was it was a dope experience
it was boozy on that one or he he was on
he was on the last show oh yeah he was
on One show and then it didn't work out
yeah
um but boof something happened where uh
I guess Fab had like maybe missed a
flight or something right and boof
literally had to hold it down for like
Fab's whole Performance Set and I think
it was like Valentine's day too and he
just like he's a problem like goof is a
problem so
um those two guys are my definitely
two current favorites like of I love
those names yeah yeah
um of course Jeff is you know Jeff is
amazing I remember seeing Jim Master Jay
live one time it was incredible yeah
Jeff is special though I saw I I when I
was living in Vegas I remember like when
he would DJ I would always I had to go
see her him or Z Trip just to be like
just to go see some ill DJ yeah yeah
yeah yeah Z Trip was dope there was a
time when Encore unplugged Jazzy Jeff
and it caused like
chaos in the Vegas nightclub scene they
like shut him off because he was he
wouldn't stop playing hip-hop this was
like the dark EDM days of Vegas yeah and
Encore there's you know shacky Green yes
so shacky I think had booked him there
and you know he's an old school hip-hop
guy
but like the GM of the club
like shut Jazzy Jeff off
because he was too hip-hop that's crazy
like can you imagine
cutting off DJ Jazzy Jeff it's like let
his he just went silent yeah but bro
Vegas used to be [__] now I remember
those times weird I remember them trying
to like go DJ Crown nightclub or some
[__] yeah did you ever do a crown yeah I
did Crown I used to I did a bunch of I
used to do Chateau oh [__] you write
Chateau a lot yeah I was that [__] huh
yeah I was at Paris it was in it was in
Paris yeah Chateau yep and then what was
the club that Ray J used to be a part of
do you remember this was like
0809 friends and you got their uh poetry
poetry I used to do poetry all the time
did you ever do strip hop I'd of course
strip Hoppers yeah we did strip hop
that's the first time I ever saw a woman
swallow an entire like animal balloon
she blew the whole [__] up it was like
the size of this table and it just went
away and she kept dancing and I was like
is her stomach actually gonna pop the
balloon and like is she gonna die or
like is she gonna yeah strip pop was the
time that was that was a little time
um and then
um yeah boo from Rogers uh what about
let's order yours
I don't know dude
all time
am's pretty [__] incredible too I
guess like for me probably I'm sorry and
and then I have to um
um
who am I what oh [__] who Am I who am I
not thinking of from I can't believe I I
just went blank from Canada
he was a DMC Champion oh a track a track
a track's a beast a track is a problem
hey track I love a track I love he's
he's see I like he might be my he might
be third for me well the reason I like
eight like guys like a track is because
I feel like a track you could throw him
in any situation any situation any
situation and he's gonna rock that [__]
any situation [__] ratchet party EDM
party doesn't matter he could go to a
[__] DMC anything's actually probably
my favorite DJ ever I bought his DVD and
[__] he's one of mine too he's one of my
favorite DJs ever like all around like
those are the kind of DJs that I like
I'm like yo if I could throw if I could
see somebody Rock whatever
and they got whatever in their Arsenal
and you know to his credit too like he
had a very successful label okay Fool's
Gold who's going you know he [__] was
Kanye's DJ like you know a track's name
needs to get he was a DMC Champion like
as a child as a [__] 13 year old
crazy you know like a track's probably
my favorite personal favorite DJ great
guy Scratch DJ I really like DJ Babu
from the B junkies baboos dope but yeah
some Club [__] bro I don't know dude
like I guess it depends on what club I'm
in because I'm so like current that I'm
like I just know if I see someone's name
on a flyer I'm like I know the music's
gonna be straight like if Dre Sinatra's
DJing I'm like cool I know it's gonna be
good of course if DJ bad is DJing I mean
I'm in La so I'm naming L.A guys yeah
I'm like I know it's going to be a good
time yeah you know what I mean Dre is
Dre is like I heard Sean Mack once oh
yeah Sean Max a great one too Sean Mack
Sean like going to Chicago he's another
one that I hated coming on after
um I love what about on the mixtape side
if we exclude clue because that's going
to be the easy one to name yeah but I
did want to again About Dre was was dope
About Dre too is like I feel like
like he's like a a little will in a way
like you know what I'm saying like Dre
is he's a [__] bro he's clutch he's
clutch at all times like you know he
saved my ass twice during Super Bowl
weekend Meek Mill hops on And Dre's just
letting [__] fly while he's performing
and he throws on one of the records that
Meeks like on the second verse of and
goes up and he looks at him like you got
my verse ready Andrea's like
in the headphones and on the Fly Like
perfect timing and I just looked at Dre
like what record was it was it [__] you
oh yes
can you drop the record and meek almost
look at him like what the [__] you're
playing this for yeah and Trey's like
and I was like Doug thank you and then
even because your [__] wasn't working
with the controller we had in the club
yeah so Dre was like I got it it's all
good yeah we worked out of Drake's
computer and then you know me and Dre
like when I first started
working a lot in La
um it there was this club called Colony
on Monday nights so All-Star Weekend in
like 2010 was in LA and I think I had a
bunch of gigs and then I got added to do
Colony that Monday of All-Star and this
was like around the time when La was
kind of like changing you know what I'm
saying and then so like the the the type
of music that I was playing and like
coming from Atlanta like I did colony
and I [__] rocked and then
um me and Dre like established this
relationship so Dre would start that
that was really when the West Coast was
kind of resurging with the sound like
rack city like the early muster records
so Dre was putting me on to all the
California music and he was like yo play
this you'll play this and then I would
take it back home and like start putting
it on Shade 45 early on because I was
familiar with it so like you know he's
he we literally have been like rock him
for a decade plus and I've been watching
them whatever happened you had a
short-lived DJ crew that was supposed to
kind of rival what the Heavy Hitters are
you talking about the Affiliates or like
the academy the academy
um so we we around
2012 2013 we wanted to Trey was a part
of it yeah Dre was a part of it amen we
had a bunch of people a part of it like
um uh [__] uh diamond cuts Mr Rogers
um it was like 15. it was like
short-lived though right well what
happened to be honest was around the
time that we launched it
I was going into my a r
um job and then we started a generation
now
started
we went into the direction of you know
the label and so I think that a lot of
my you know bandwidth yeah our bandwidth
and just like our focus wasn't
necessarily on what we had set out to do
with the DJ crew at the time so it kind
of didn't it didn't become what it
became but you know like you know those
we're still proud of you know the the
Arsenal or the the the collective that
we put together and then there are
people that still represent or you know
right like still family
um but then you said something before
that I wanted to bring up was it about
you had said
in the club you you were about to name
somebody else
I was just saying that like if I go to a
club I if I see someone's name on a
flyer I'm like there's just like a few
names and I'm like oh
you know like I love bad is dope
um yeah and then Sean Mack Sean Max dope
yeah I mean who else we've talked about
eight eight track
oh you said okay so taking away kalu you
said a mixtapes oh mixtapes yeah yeah so
if you take clue out the who's who's
your personal favorite mixtape DJs after
yourself obviously
because there's been there were some I
mean there's guys like Big Mike okay Jay
Smalls then there's who kid there's I
mean so of course I'm gonna say Canon
first
um and then I'm gonna go Green Lantern
who kid like Greenland I don't know who
kid are
are why we are where we are like we we
would we would religiously
listen and cop greens tapes and who kids
tapes and and really for two different
reasons too like because totally
different styles of DJs two totally
different styles of DJing like green
skill wise creativity wise like actually
making records making records like you
know
drops just you know sound wise nobody
could touch green and then who kid for
like marketing like like the the way he
was packaging his the mixtapes like the
fold outs yeah the sponsorships like he
it just was bigger than life like I
think he's the first person I've ever
seen like with a fold out like you know
like where you get to see the energy it
was not just a piece of paper like it
would open it up and it'd be like all
this [__] on there and these you know
accolades and sponsorships and all this
[__] and was like next level [__] you
know and it was at a time when fifth was
the biggest thing in in rap music
um so I love who cared for for that and
his and his personality as well like
um you know it's just a [__] he's a
fool for sure he's just a [__] fool
um so yeah that would those would be my
go-to's
um am I leaving anybody out
hmm so we got a clue green light green
we got who kid
um
yeah I mean early on
you know I I I'd show some love to SNS
and doo-wop for early on in my career
you know for being inspirations